je suis tentée par toutes les nouveautés
la nouvelle vue pour moi c'est pas des
blagues
j'ai essayé
[Musique]
oui mademoiselle la nouvelle vague des
copains ce n'est pas de la blague c'est
une réalité démographique
tous les jeudis à boulogne rue de sèvres
une cinquantaine de jeunes gens font
sagement la queue en rêvant il le joue
ni à la marelle ni aux billes ils ont
seulement le trac de passer à côté de la
chance qui leur est offerte toutes les
semaines par une petite annonce parue
dans la presse
[Musique]
les gens m'appellent
l'idole des jeunes il en est même qui
m'envient mais ils ne savent pas d'un
rang la vie
parfois jeu
pourquoi faut-il que le bateau sont à
quand le soleil se lève encore dans le
ciel bleu
quand nous vivons
le temps des fiançailles
pourquoi faut-il que vienne le temps des
adieux
[Musique]
oh
blanche de corfou
[Musique]
oh
blanches roses
blanche chat
la nuit je pense à vous
belle aux guitares tu es mon espoir
jolie guitare tu aimes ou soleil quand
je te vois tu t'es comme un miroir tu es
ma petite merveille
jour mon père dit fiston je vois sortir
le soir
à ton âge il ya des choses qu'un garçon
doit savoir les filles tu sais méfie toi
c'est parce que tu crois
sont
ça va pas
[Musique]
et les communes
et
les communes
lui
et moi pourquoi tu changes tous les
diables sont en jeu pourquoi tu mets mon
coeur à deux pas de là tu ne dis pas de
moi
mais c'est merlen sebha
et pour me dire à genève
tu fais marcher le tube paris petit
schéma joli petit
j'aimais bien
ml
nous que toi semaines que l'on s'est
rencontré
à
toi je ne vivais pas
j'étais triste à mourir
tué près de moi
je encore sourire je les petites
chaînage lee petit chez da oui c'est toi
qui as plus mon coeur je
on sait que
jamais lorsque je les ai rencontrés
dans les rues quand on voit chez
tous mes amis mon envie
yves bot je crois qu'ils ont compris et
wahaha
je vais faire ma vie
c'est la chanson si douce
que me chanter
[Musique]
rien de vraiment c'est
comme dopés
[Musique]
un typé
les garçons et les filles de mon âge ça
mandat les rues de tarbes
tous les garçons et les filles dans mon
âge avait bien ce que c'est d'être et la
main dans la main
et les dieux
les yeux ils s'en vont
amoureux
sans peur du lendemain
mon petit train de banlieue sembadel
matin pourtant tout heureux bonheur des
refrains et quand arrive la belle sait
ce qu'il va mieux qu'hier à travers la
gazon derrière les carreaux qu'on peut
apercevoir la dame sans chapeau
contemplant leur miroir et dans le fond
entre quevilly un vieux monsieur fait
des mots croisés moi j'aime bien
mon vieux petit train
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le monde
réfléchis bien
mais c'est tout mal
on
[Musique]
le temps
ce sens
moment
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est mon nom tout souviendra ton vieux
père est
belle de jour
belles perles comme
elle te vendent en fous de joie food ou
de louer noir est fou d'elle deux jours
avez vous alors non bon alors vous avez
quel âge 16 ans et demi 16 ans et demi
et est ce que les filles vous ont déjà
rendu fou de douleur qui ont encore à
vous croyez ce que vous pouvez chanter
ses chansons vraiment avec le coeur
qu'il faut puisque oui
oui ce sont des paroles pour vous oui
vous préférez l'américain aux français
ouais quand vous n'avez pas les français
enfin j'essaie de passer chez une
vieille cheminée hallyday oui je préfère
les américains pourquoi ils ont plus
ils ont plus de rythme est ce que vous
comprenez ce qu'ils chantent ah non
non mais ça fait rien
qu'est-ce que vous avez l'argent sans
beaucoup de choses beaucoup de joueurs
j'aime le chan la scène je me public
j'aime chanter ça m'apportera joie et
l'entente que vous chantez non combien
de temps
un mois est ce que c'est le côté
matériel qui vous attire aussi
bon c'est de l'argent la facilité
notamment sur secondaire c'est surtout
la chanson vous aimeriez réussi en une
chanson oui pourquoi ce que ça me plaît
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans cette
réussite
relâche j'ai pas tout quoi
parce que vous entourer cette réussite
de
deux succès matériel ou est-ce que c'est
plutôt intellectuelle je vous
intellectuelle est-ce que devenu ici au
studio pour au fond pour enregistrer un
disque qu'est-ce qui vous tendent
là-dedans c'est parce que je voulais
tenter ma chance et tout comme anthony
oui pourquoi l'attention
parce que c'est une chose qui m'a
toujours tenté j'ai eu envie de faire de
la chanson depuis longtemps oui puis
surtout depuis qu'on laisse la place aux
jeunes mécontents laissent leur chance
parce que vous croyez vous la méritez
cette chance
qu'est ce que c'est qu'une idole des
jeunes
a grandi à chansons
puis qu'il vous propose de passer quoi
est-ce que vous espère être un grand de
la chanson au repos lui même en
travaillant ou quelques chic jacques
slogan gérard lefebvre jean paul guiter
n'est pas encore les idoles des jeunes
mais voulait fabriquer
ragan vous avez vu combien depuis deux
mois ces jeunes et bien écoutez je vais
vous répondre exactement dans l'ain du
512 will claye les statistiques sont à
jour oui
512 environ bruit depuis depuis deux
mois peut prendre tous les jeudis tous
les jeudis
qu'est ce que vous en pensez cet
attachant ce qu'ils sont ridicules
pratique lorsque vous les juges et non
en aucun cas
en aucun cas ils sont ridicules
bien sûr on trouve de temps en temps des
phénomènes c'est à dire ce que je peux
appeler des gens inconscients mme affret
la plupart quand même sont des gens qui
pensent beaucoup pas la chanson qui
savent qu'on peut faire actuellement
carrière très rapidement dans la chanson
et qui évidemment en venant ne
s'imagine que ça peut être plus facile
que ça l'est en réalité et très souvent
je leur dis vous avez des possibilités
vous avez même du talent une nature mais
attention il faut bosser avant
d'envisager ce métier sur le plan
professionnel que ça pour ceux qui ont
réussi et qui vont faire tout de suite
un disque ces quelques jours après le
contact brutal avec anwar leur tête
grossiront comme les affiches leur voix
amplifiée sur toutes les fréquences
iront faire rêver les copains cinéastes
photographes une meute féroce guettera
désormais jour et nuit la défaillance
ils n'ont pas 20 ans livré en pâture aux
projecteurs et au public il s'apprête à
vivre à toute vitesse dans le vacarme
[Musique]